The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
Let's try to discuss a bit how
things relate to physics.
There are two main things I
want to discuss.
One of them is what curl says
about force fields and,
in particular,a nice
consequence of that concerning
gravitational attraction.
More about curl.
If we have a velocity field,
then we have seen that the curl
measures the rotation affects.
More precisely curl v measures
twice the angular velocity,
or maybe I should say the
angular velocity vector because
it also includes the axis of
rotation.
I should say maybe for the
rotation part of a motion.
For example,
just to remind you,
I mean we have seen this guy a
couple of times,
but if I give you a uniform
rotation motion about the z,
axes.
That is a vector field in which
the trajectories are going to be
circles centered in the z-axis
and our vector field is just
going to be tangent to each of
these circles.
And, if you look at it from
above, then you will have this
rotation vector field that we
have seen many times.
Typically, the velocity vector
for this would be minus yi plus
yj times maybe a number that
represents how fast we are
spinning,
the angular velocity in
gradients per second.
And then.
if you compute the curl of
this, you will end up with two
omega times k.
Now, the other kinds of vector
fields we have seen physically
are force fields.
The question is what does the
curl of a force field mean?
What can we say about that?
The interpretation is a little
bit less obvious,
but let's try to get some idea
of what it might be.
I want to remind you that if we
have a solid in a force field,
we can measure the torque
exerted by the force on the
solid.
Maybe first I should remind you
about what torque is in space.
Let's say that I have a piece
of solid with a mass,
delta m for example,
and I have a force that is
being exerted to it.
Let's say that maybe my force
might be F times delta m.
If you think,
for example,
a gravitational field.
The gravitational force is
actually the gravitational field
times the mass.
I mean you can forget delta m
if you don't like it.
And let's say that the position
vector, which should be aiming
for the origin,
R is here.
And now let's say that maybe
this guy is at the end of some
arm or some metal thing and I
want to hold it in place.
The force is going to exert a
torque relative to the origin
that will try to measure how
much I am trying to swing this
guy around the origin.
And, consequently,
how much effort I have to exert
if I want to actually maintain
its place by just holding it at
the end of the stick here.
So the torque is now a vector,
which is just the cross-product
of a position vector with a
force.
What the torque measures again
is the rotation effects of the
force.
And if you remember the
principle that the derivative of
velocity,
which is acceleration,
is force divided by mass then
the derivative of angular
velocity should be angular
acceleration which is related to
the torque per unit mass.
To just remind you,
if I look at translation
motions,
say I am just looking at the
point mass so there are no
rotation effects then force
divided by mass is acceleration,
which is the derivative of
velocity.
And so what I am claiming is
that for rotation effects we
have a similar law,
which maybe you have seen in
8.01.
Well, it is one of the
important things of solid
mechanics, which is the torque
of a force divided by the moment
of inertia.
I am cheating a little bit here.
If you can see how I am
cheating then I am sure you know
how to state it correctly.
And if you don't see how I am
cheating then let's just ignore
the details.
[LAUGHTER]
Is angular acceleration.
And angular acceleration is the
derivative of angular velocity.
If I think of curl as an
operation,
which from a velocity field
gives the angular velocity of
its rotation effects,
then you see that the curl of
an acceleration field gives the
angular acceleration in the
rotation part of the
acceleration effects.
And, therefore,
the curl of a force field
measures the torque per unit
moment of inertia.
It measures how much torque its
force field exerts on a small
test solid placed in it.
If you have a small solid
somewhere, the curl will just
measure how much your solid
starts spinning if you leave it
in this force field.
In particular,
a force field with no curl is a
force field that does not
generate any rotation motion.
That means if you put an object
in there that is completely
immobile and you leave it in
that force field,
well, of course it might
accelerate in some direction but
it won't start spinning.
While, if you put it in there
spinning already in some
direction, it should continue to
spin in the same way.
Of course, maybe there will be
friction and things like that
which will slow it down but this
force field is not responsible
for it.
The cool consequence of this is
if a force field F derives from
a potential -- That is what we
have seen about conservative
forces.
Our main concern so far has
been to say if we have a
conservative force field it
means that the work of a force
is the change in the energy.
And, in particular,
we cannot get energy for free
out of it.
And the change in the potential
energy is going to be the change
in kinetic energy.
You have conservation of energy
principles.
There is another thing that we
know now because if a force
derives from a potential then
that means its curl is zero.
That is the criterion we have
seen for a vector field to
derive from a potential.
And if the curl is zero then it
means that this force does not
generate any rotation effects.
For example,
if you try to understand where
the earth comes from,
well, the earth is spinning on
itself as it goes around the
sun.
And you might wonder where that
comes from.
Is that causes by gravitational
attraction?
And the answer is no.
Gravitational attraction in
itself cannot cause the earth to
start spinning faster or slower,
at least if you assume the
earth to be a solid,
which actually is false.
I mean basically the reason why
the earth is spinning is because
it was formed spinning.
It didn't start spinning
because of gravitational
effects.
And that is a rather deep
purely mathematical consequence
of understanding gravitation in
this way.
It is quite spectacular that
just by abstract thinking we got
there.
What is the truth?
Well, the truth is the earth,
the moon and everything is
slightly deformable.
And so there is deformation,
friction effects,
tidal effects and so on.
And these actually cause
rotations to get slightly
synchronized with each other.
For example,
if you want to explain why the
moon is always showing the same
face to the earth,
why the rotation of a moon on
itself is synchronized with its
revolution around the earth,
which is actually explained by
friction effects over time and
the gravitational attraction of
the earth and the moon.
There is something there,
but if you took perfectly
rigid, solid bodies then
gravitation would never cause
any rotation effects.
Of course that tells us that we
do not know how to answer the
question of why is the earth
spinning.
That will be left for another
physics class.
I don't have a good answer to
that.
That was kind of 8.01-ish.
Let me now move forward to 8.02
stuff.
I want to tell you things about
electric and magnetic fields.
And, in fact,
something that is known as
Maxwell's equations.
Just a quick poll.
How many of you have been
taking 8.02 or something like
that?
OK. That is not very many.
For most of you this is a
preview.
If you have been taking 8.02,
have you seen Maxwell's
equations, at least part of
them?
Yeah.
OK.
Then I am sure,
in that case,
you know better than me what I
am going to talk about because I
am not a physicist.
But just in case.
Maxwell's equations govern how
electric and magnetic fields
behave, how they are caused by
electric charges and their
motions.
And, in particular,
they explain a lot of things
such as how electric devices
work, but also how
electromagnetic waves propagate.
In particular,
that explains light and all
sorts of waves.
It is thanks to them,
you know, your cell phone,
laptops and things like that
work.
Anyway.
Hopefully most of you know that
the electric field is a vector
field that basically tells you
what kind of force will be
exerted on a charged particle
that you put in it.
If you have a particle carrying
an electric charge then this
vector field will tell you,
basically there will be an
electric force which is the
charge times E that will be
exerted on that particle.
And that is what is
responsible, for example,
for the flow of electrons when
you have a voltage difference.
Because classically this guy is
a gradient of a potential.
And that potential is just
electric voltage.
The magnetic field is a little
bit harder to think about if you
have never seen it in physics,
but it is what is causing,
for example,
magnets to work.
Well, basically it is a force
that is also expressed in terms
of a vector field usually called
B.
Some people call it H but I am
going to use B.
And that force tends to cause
it, if you have a moving charged
particle, to deflect its
trajectory and start rotating in
a magnetic field.
What it does is not quite as
easy as what an electric field
does.
Just to give you formulas,
the force caused by the
electric field is the charge
times the electric field.
And the force caused by the
magnetic field,
I am never sure about the sign.
Is that the correct sign?
Good.
Now, the question is we need to
understand how these fields
themselves are caused by the
charged particles that are
placed in them.
There are various laws in there
that explain what is going on.
Let me focus today on the
electric field.
Maxwell's equations actually
tell you about div and curl of
these fields.
Let's look at div and curl of
the electric field.
The first equation is called
the Gauss-Coulomb law.
And it says that the divergence
of the electric field is equal
to,
so this is a just a physical
constant,
and what it is equal to depends
on what units you are using.
And this guy rho,
well, it is not the same rho as
in spherical coordinates because
physicists somehow pretended
they used that letter first.
It is the electric charge
density.
It is the amount of electric
charge per unit volume.
What this tells you is that
divergence of E is caused by the
presence of electric charge.
In particular,
if you have an empty region of
space or a region where nothing
has electrical charge then E has
divergence equal to zero.
Now, that looks like a very
abstract strange equation.
I mean it is a partial
differential equation satisfied
by the electric field E.
And that is not very intuitive
in any way.
What is actually more intuitive
is what we get if we apply the
divergence theorem to this
equation.
If I think now about any closed
surface,
and I want to think about the
flux of the electric field out
of that surface,
we haven't really thought about
what the flux of a force field
does.
And I don't want to get into
that because there is no very
easy answer in general,
but I am going to explain soon
how this can be useful
sometimes.
Let's say that we want to find
the flux of the electric field
out of a closed surface.
Then, by the divergence
theorem,
that is equal to the triple
integral of a region inside of
div E dV,
which is by the equation one
over epsilon zero,
that is this constant,
times the triple integral of
rho dV.
But now, if I integrate the
charge density over the entire
region,
then what I will get is
actually the total amount of
electric charge inside the
region.
That is the electric charge in
D.
This one tells us,
in a more concrete way,
how electric charges placed in
here influence the electric
field around them.
In particular,
one application of that is if
you want to study capacitors.
Capacitors are these things
that store energy by basically
you have two plates,
one that contains positive
charge and a negative charge.
Then you have a voltage between
these plates.
And, basically,
that can provide electrical
energy to power maybe an
electric circuit.
That is not really a battery
because it doesn't store energy
in large enough amounts.
But, for example,
that is why when you switch
your favorite gadget off it
doesn't actually go off
immediately but somehow you see
things dimming progressively.
There is a capacitor in there.
If you want to understand how
the voltage and the charge
relate to each other,
the voltage is obtained by
integrating the electric field
from one plate to the other
plate.
And the charges in the plates
are what causes the electric
field between the plates.
That is how you can get the
relation between voltage and
charge in these guys.
That is an example of
application of that.
Now, of course,
if you haven't seen any of this
then maybe it is a little bit
esoteric, but that will tell you
part of what you will see in
8.02.
Questions?
I see some confused faces.
Well, don't worry.
It will make sense some day.
[LAUGHTER]
The next one I want to tell you
about is Faraday's law.
In case you are confused,
Maxwell's equations,
there are four equations in the
set of Maxwell's equations and
most of them don't carry
Maxwell's name.
That is a quirky feature.
That one tells you about the
curl of the electric field.
Now, depending on your
knowledge,
you might start telling me that
the curl of the electric field
has to be zero because it is the
gradient of the electric
potential.
I told you this stuff about
voltage.
Well, that doesn't account for
the fact that sometimes you can
create voltage out of nowhere
using magnetic fields.
And, in fact,
you have a failure of
conservativity of the electric
force if you have a magnetic
field.
What this one says is the curl
of E is not zero but rather it
is the derivative of the
magnetic field with respect to
time.
More precisely it tells you
that what you might have learned
about electric fields deriving
from electric potential becomes
false if you have a variable
magnetic field.
And just to tell you again that
is a strange partial
differential equation relating
these two vector fields.
To make sense of it one should
use Stokes' theorem.
If we apply Stokes' theorem to
compute the work done by the
electric field around a closed
curve,
that means you have a wire in
there and you want to find the
voltage along the wire.
Now there is a strange thing
because classically you would
say, well, if I just have a wire
with nothing in it there is no
voltage on it.
Well, a small change in plans.
If you actually have a varying
magnetic field that passes
through that wire then that will
actually generate voltage in it.
That is how a transformer works.
When you plug your laptop into
the wall circuit,
you don't actually feed it
directly 110 volts,
120 volts or whatever.
There is a transformer in there.
What the transformer does it
takes some input voltage and
passes that through basically a
loop of wire.
Not much seems to be happening.
But now you have another loops
of wire that is intertwined with
it.
Somehow the magnetic field
generated by it,
and it has to be a donating
current.
The donating current varies
over time in the first wire.
That generates a magnetic field
that varies over time,
so that causes 2B by 2t and
that causes curl of the electric
field.
And the curl of the electric
field will generate voltage
between these two guys.
And that is how a transformer
works.
It uses Stokes' theorem.
More precisely,
how do we find the voltage
between these two points?
Well, let's close the loop and
let's try to figure out the
voltage inside this loop.
To find a voltage along a
closed curve places in a varying
magnetic field,
we have to do the line integral
along a closed curve of the
electric field.
And you should think of this as
the voltage generated in this
circuit.
That will be the flux for this
surface bounded by the curve of
curl E dot dS.
That is what Stokes' theorem
says.
And now if you combine that
with Faraday's law you end up
with the flux trough S of minus
dB over dt.
And, of course, you could take,
if your loop doesn't move over
time,
I mean there is a different
story if you start somehow
taking your wire and somehow
moving it inside the field.
But if you don't do that,
if it is the field that is
moving then you just can take
the dB by dt outside.
But let's not bother.
Again, what this equation tells
you is that if the magnetic
field changes over time then it
creates, just out of nowhere,
and electric field.
And that electric field can be
used to power up things.
I don't really claim that I
have given you enough details to
understand how they work,
but basically these equations
are the heart of understanding
how things like capacitors and
transformers work.
And they also explain a lot of
other things,
but I will leave that to your
physics teachers.
Just for completeness,
I will just give you the last
two equations in that.
I am not even going to try to
explain them too much.
One of them says that the
divergence of the magnetic field
is zero,
which somehow is fortunate
because otherwise you would run
into trouble trying to
understand surface independence
when you apply Stokes' theorem
in here.
And the last one tells you how
the curl of the magnetic field
is caused by motion of charged
particles.
In fact, let's say that the
curl of B is given by this kind
of formula, well,
J is what is called the vector
of current density.
It measures the flow of
electrically charged particles.
You get this guy when you start
taking charged particles,
like electrons maybe,
and moving them around.
And, of course,
that is actually part of how
transformers work because I have
told you running the AC through
the first loop generates a
magnetic field.
Well, how does it do that?
It is thanks to this equation.
If you have a current passing
in the loop that causes a
magnetic field and,
in turn, for the other equation
that causes an electric field,
which in turn causes a current.
It is all somehow intertwined
in a very intricate way and is
really remarkable how well that
works in practice.
I think that is basically all I
wanted to say about 8.02.
I don't want to put your
physics teachers out of a job.
[LAUGHTER]
If you haven't seen any of this
before,
I understand that this is
probably not detailed enough to
be really understandable,
but hopefully it will make you
a bit curious about that and
prompt you to take that class
someday and maybe even remember
how it relates to 18.02.